you
Theatre England permanent secretary in
the Swedish Academy host the lucky one
of this year the lucky one this year is
a Chinese writer by the name of Mohan
it's it's actually a pen name his his
real name is Goyal more he is known
under his pen name
Mohan could you give me a short
introduction to his life and work please
his life is I think quite unusual for
being a Nobel laureate he is born in a
peasant family in 1955 in the Shandong
Province he left school at 12 years old
and started to work in the fields
together with the adults and eventually
gained education after he managed to
join the army and then it was educated
and it picked up writing and he did his
literary debut in 1981 he made his
breakthrough at least in China in 84 and
then in 85 years it was big success read
Sorbonne the red field which has also
been made into a movie and given an
award at the Berlin Film Festival I
think perhaps if people have heard of
more units it as the who wrote the
original for this movie how well-known
is here all over the world are there
many translations for instance I don't
know how well-known he is but he is for
instance in both Japan and France almost
his entire work has been translated and
in a very good way
stan is pretty well covered in in
English and German and so on I don't
know about other countries now have you
been able to talk to him today well I
had talked to him not so much with him
mr. moe doesn't understand English or
Swedish and I don't understand Chinese
but luckily we have a member of the
Academy who is fluent in in Chinese so I
had an interpreter when I talked to him
and what were his his reactions he said
he was overjoyed and scared because his
life seems like a real success story
from rags to riches well yes in a way
but the interesting thing that he we
phoned him in it he was at home in go me
where he lives with his father it's now
an int but all the important seems in
his books he is writing about the
peasantry is writing about mainly about
life in the countryside there is a very
strong moral core in it it's about
ordinary people struggling struggling to
survive struggling for the dignity many
times sometimes winning but most of the
time losing but he was also doing it in
a in a rather unique ways he's really I
guess the basis for his books they were
laid as he was a child and listened to
all these Chinese folk tales so the term
magic realism has been used about his
work but I think that is sort of
belittling him because he is not someone
who's just simply picked up from Garcia
Marquez or something that he's done
something that is quite unique something
very much of his own with with
that is supernatural going into the
ordinary reality and so on yes it's an
extremely skillful narrator and which
book should I start with if I were to
care to know his work well why not start
off with it with the garlic balance
it's it's a novel based on a only true
incident in the 80s in in China because
it is not just writing about history but
it's also writing about contemporary
China and it's it's an incident that
happened in the 80s where there were
riots due to a bust in the India in the
garlic market but that is just a
centerpiece for a a big store evolving
about a lot a lot of different people
thank you mr. England permanent
secretary of the Swedish Academy